a Heil pad and you're a broadcaster
you're a YouTuber we met early you've
been on GB news before yeah but we we
met today for the first time and and you
are really wildly enthusiastic about
this why absolutely it's because as you
mentioned actually 90 of um central
banks in the world are currently looking
at um building Central Bank digital
currencies so it's not just that they're
traceable the issue with that is the
fact that it's actually programmable so
if for whatever reason you say the wrong
thing online you hold the incorrect
opinion that money can actually be
programmed to be used against you so
during the height of the pandemic in
Canada for example if you weren't
vaccinated what happened is you weren't
allowed to spend um going to certain
shops you had to be chaperoned if you
wanted to buy certain items we could get
to a point where they say you know for
the better good of the environment
um you know you're only allowed to spend
money on certain items whether it's um
you know you get a carbon allowance a
meat allowance whatever it is and so
instead of having to have that chaperone
and to make sure that you spend the
money on those certain things you can
just program them money which basically
eliminates any third party and it
creates a much more so you're suggesting
you're suggesting
that through Central Bank digital
currencies governments could effectively
freeze our accounts if we say something
right they're doing it now in Canada we
even just saw the Kanye West JP Morgan
don't want to have him as a customer
anymore because he said the incorrect
thing we're seeing it with PayPal PayPal
recently um just blocked a bunch of
accounts because they gave out
misinformation what's regarded as
misinformation is constantly changing on
a daily basis so it's something like
Bitcoin nobody can touch your money
um the the uh the government in Canada
actually tried to stop those Bitcoin
addresses of the truckers who are
protesting to have body autonomy they
weren't able to do that because they
held Bitcoin yeah and I think this is
what happened with the truckers isn't it
because they did get their bank accounts
Frozen and then there was a big online
fundraising campaign via Bitcoin to help
them exactly and the key Point here is
that a lot of the um Bitcoin that people
hold are held on exchanges which are
still centralized platforms so the
important thing is to actually take
self-custody and hold it in a um by
yourself without any third party you
hold the key so that's the key Point
that's the way that you can become
completely Sovereign I understand that
and yet you know there are a lot of
people
out there and they're probably a bit
older than you and they struggle
with modern technology I I would think
you know 50 plus of the over 40s
struggle with uh with some form of
modern communication this is quite
daunting for them isn't it it absolutely
is and that's why you know I do what I
do I have a book called undressing
Bitcoin I talk um on GB news and we want
to educate people and teach them how to
take self-sovereignty and also have
these conversations so a lot of people
tend to think you know Bitcoin is
confiscatable because of what happened
in Canada well actually it's not it's
not confiscatable and also people think
you know um it's it's uh full of scams
well it's not it's all about education
and that's what conferences like this
are for that's what conversations like
this are for can the average 80 year old
understand the concept of a digital
wallet and operate effectively with it
how difficult is it my grandfather is 93
years old and he does get it I've had
conversations with him up in Leeds I'm
in Yorkshire and he absolutely
understands it I've given him my book
um and and he gets it so I think
conversations like this are so important
and you know if they can lock you on
your home and if they can take away your
job because you don't want to put
something inside your body then they are
coming for money and I just want to be
clear that money really is the fuel I
mean it's the energy which fuels your
life and if you don't have freedom over
your money you don't have freedom to do
anything we can't come here and have
these conversations
um in America for example I know they're
concerned about the second amendment
being taken away from them we don't
really need to get rid of the Second
Amendment you just program the money so
you can't go buy a gun with it how far
away is this because I mean I hear that
Norway is pushing ahead with this
concept of a central bank digital
currency very very quickly how far away
are we well I think we are as near as uh
the people at the world economic Forum
want us to be it's all a big conspiracy
it's not a conspiracy they told us at
the world economic Forum they literally
said in Davos earlier this year they
said that if they were to create some
kind of Central Bank digital currency
busy they would need to implement a Bill
of Rights to ensure that our rights are
not impinged on just because of the
tyrannical nature of this type of
technology and that concerns me it
concerns me because during the lockdowns
they didn't abide by the Nuremberg code
which meant you weren't allowed to force
people to put foreign substances inside
their bodies so why would they abide by
um some Bill of Rights which they
created to protect themselves well I
have to say Larry you believe in this
very strongly so this is the future this
is the future and this is the only way
to remain Sovereign over your money it's
so important if you have an opinion
which is controversial please hold
Bitcoin because they are literally
coming from your money well the layer
helper message is and it's a familiar
one it's Take Back Control that in
effect I think is what she's saying it's
a bit like brexit